non
alors que les relations entre américains
et soviétiques sont plutôt au beau fixe
la météo contrarie leur sommet de malte
la tempête souffle en méditerranée les
négociations et le dîner de ce soir ont
été annulées le président bush est
bloqué sur son bateau des blocages au
contraire dans la sphère du foulard
islamique au collège de créer deux des
trois jeunes musulmanes ont accepté
d'autres et leur foulard pendant les
heures de cours
la politique qu à faire comme mon parti
socialiste réunit ce week end à paris un
problème commun préserver l'unité menacé
par les courants contraires tout les
rénovateurs le 7 décembre 1988 la terre
tremblait en arménie un an plus tard les
reporters d'antenne 2 se sont rendus sur
place
leur constat édition spéciale à la fin
de ce journal
madame monsieur bonsoir les hommes
d'état aime les symboles on le sait et
ce n'est peut-être pas par hasard que 45
ans après le partage du monde à yalta
américains et soviétiques ont choisi
malte qui se dit en anglais malta pour
tenir cette réunion au sommet historique
dans la mesure où elle intervient au
beau milieu des bouleversements de
l'europe de l'est ce qui n'avait sans
doute pas prévu en revanche c'est qu'au
moment où les relations entre moscou et
washington sont au beau fixe une
véritable tempête en méditerranée
viendrait troubler leurs discussions qui
devaient avoir lieu sur deux navires de
guerre ancré dans la rade de laval est
le principal port de l'île de man
à tel point que la deuxième séance de
négociation qui devait avoir lieu cet
après-midi et le dîner de ce soir ont dû
être repoussée car le président
américain george bush n'a pu quitter le
croiseur qui lui sert d'hôtel pendant ce
sommes sur place de nos envoyés spéciaux
jacquat bouchard claude sicard sur le
croiseur belle tu n'as tous feux allumés
georges vous se demandent ce soir à quel
moment il pourra rejoindre michael
gorbatchev comme de rescapés qui ont
bravé la tempête
les deux grands s'étaient rencontrés en
début de journée sur le paquebot
soviétique maxime gorki
un premier face à face dans ce sommet de
malte ballotté par la furie des éléments
ils n'ont d'ailleurs pas altéré la bonne
humeur générale et monsieur gorbatchev
très envers vous êtes observé qu'avant
de songer à réduire les effectifs
militaires
il serait peut être judicieux d'envoyer
à la casse ces bateaux inaccessible par
gros temps la colère des flots avait en
effet empêché le rendez vous prévu sur
le croiseur soviétique cela va ancrer
dans une baie et c'est donc à bord du
maxime gorki un bateau de croisière de
belle taille
amarré à quai que les deux grands
avaient enchaîné une première séance de
travail et le déjeuner leur programme
initial prévoyait une dizaine d'heures
d'entretiens répartis sur les deux
journées du week end avec en vedette les
bouleversements intervenus en europe de
l'est ce sur fond de projet de réduction
des contingents militaires américains et
soviétiques en europe à rome michael
gorbatchev avait dit en substance
renforçons le climat de paix autrement
dit taillon dans les budgets des armées
et tout le reste en découlera c'est sa
réponse à un george bush qui vient de
déclarer publiquement
mettons fin une fois pour toutes à la
guerre froide aussi contrariés soit il
est rendu chaotique par une météo
épouvantable ce sommet de maths aura
connu un début prometteur et c'est
exactement ce que souhaitait george bush
qui est profondément désireux d'établir
avec mikhaïl gorbatchev une relation
personnelle solide
on imagine aisément que dans ce type de
réunion au sommet entre les deux chefs
d'état des plus grandes puissances du
monde des décisions ou les accords les
plus importants sont gardés secrets on
peut donc s'intéresser également à tout
ce qui fait le folklore entre guillemets
l'ambiance jacques dallest
une véritable journée de chiens en
réalité à bord de ses vedettes dans la
tempête le président george bush qui
regagne le croiseur américain belt nappe
après les discussions de la matinée et
le déjeuner sur le maxime gorki
les vagues étaient tellement fortes que
les marins ont dû se reprendre à trois
fois pour accoster le croiseur pendant
ce temps la dame gorbatchev quittant le
maxime gorki qui sert d'hôtel à la
délégation soviétique a profité d'une
timide éclaircie pour une rapide visite
dans le centre ville de laval est mais
c'est ce matin très tôt que les deux
délégations ont pris conscience que la
tempête avec des vents de force 8 allait
perturber ce saumur la cérémonie
d'accueil qui devaient avoir lieu sur le
croiseur soviétique a été annulée et le
président bush s'est rendu sur le maxime
gorki qui lui à quai était beaucoup plus
protégés que les deux croiseurs à terre
certains câbles servant aux
communications ont été endommagés
la presse et les équipes de télévision
s'organise dans le vent et les
bourrasques
depuis que les deux grands se rencontre
pour parler de la paix c'est la première
fois une telle tempête vient troubler un
sommet
oui pendant la durée de ce sommet les
turbulences en europe de l'est n'ont pas
cessé pour autant la liste est longue
mais passionnante je pense ce soit en
allemagne de l'est par exemple dans la
chasse aux membres du parti communiste
corrompu arrestation de deux
responsables de très haut niveau
il ya quelques instants à prague lara
nous la radio a annoncé le désarmement
des milices populaires à partir de
demain
et puis ce matin le vice premier
ministre tchèque au slovaque avait
annoncé lui qu'il n'était pas hostile à
l'installation d'une économie de marché
c'est-à-dire capitaliste en quelque
sorte dans son pays et puis le parlement
de chèque lui a voté un texte condamnant
l'intervention soviétique en 1968 et
monsieur gorbatchev lui-même reconnaît
que l'entrée des troupes du pacte de
varsovie à prague en 68 n'était pas une
réponse appropriée ce sont ses termes
enfin en urss même le prix nobel de la
paix andreï sakharov le plus célèbre
dissident soviétique appel à une grève
générale symbolique de 2 heures en urss
le 11 décembre prochain à la veille de
la réunion des députés du rss pour
demander la suppression de l'article de
la constitution soviétique établissant
le rôle dirigeant du parti communiste
dans le pays et puis enfin même en
roumanie ça bouge un tout petit peu avec
beaucoup de prudence et sans se remettre
en cause monsieur chaouchi secours
reconnaît les carences de l'état et du
parti communiste room aux philippines
maintenant la mutinerie militaire n'a
pas réussi madame akino a repris la
situation en main avec l'aide il faut
dire est stratégique de l'armée de l'air
américaine père sébastien les dernières
poches de résistance aux troupes
loyalistes et suis toujours des tirs de
roquettes à manille le coup d'état
échoué mais les combats se poursuivent
entre la présidente et le chef de la
rébellion l'ex-colonel gringo nasa un
véritable bras de fer s'est engagé
oui les douleurs les sont deux choix se
rendre ou mourir nous sommes prêts à
mourir
deuxième tentative de push pour l'ancien
colonel de l'armée régulière et deuxième
échec mais pour madame akino le 1er
décembre marque la sixième tentative de
coup d'état depuis son accession au
pouvoir
en 86 si cette nouvelle alerte prouve
que les anciens partisans du dictateur
marcos n'ont pas désarmé
elle montre aussi à quel point la
pasionaria des philippines a perdu de
sonora
car déterminante a été cette fois
l'intervention de l'armée de l'air
américaine face au soutien un peu
tardive de sa propre armée en france
maintenant la polémique autour du port
du foulard islamique à trouver un début
de solution de déblocage dirons nous au
collège de creil où d'où était partie la
sphère les deux soeurs fatima et la
ilaha chahboun ont accepté ce matin
d'assister aux cours en notant leur
foulard une troisième élève continuelle
de refuser chantal qui merde c'est sous
la neige que la situation s'est enfin
dégeler au collège gabriel aves de creil
après deux mois et demi de polémique et
de revirements explosif et très
médiatisée fatima et leïla ont choisi de
retirer définitivement leur foulard
pendant la classe à la grande surprise
du proviseur qui n'avait pas été informé
de cette nouvelle décision de la famille
à chahbounia cela m'a été annoncée par
le téléphone intérieur l'établissement
et c'est un renseignement que vous vous
aviez donné
maintenant j'en ai confirmation de la
date de l'ignorance accusent de ne pas
porter des fleurs dont vous savez qui
les a convaincus qui devait plus porter
pas je ne suis pas dans le secret des
dieux non
m'enfin j'accueille avec joie cette
cette solution cette décision vous
pensez que c'est grâce à votre action
notre action n'est certainement pas
étrangère à une telle décision tout de
même
mais enfin quelque chose à peser et
j'ignore quoi de source officielle et
religieuse les deux jeunes filles et
leurs familles auraient été depuis
plusieurs jours très encadrés et
conseillés par la collectivité
maghrébine de creil dans un même temps
l'avis du conseil d'état en confirmant
les pouvoirs des chefs d'établissements
scolaires a sans aucun doute décider la
famille h à bout à faire un pas pour une
meilleure intégration au sein de l'école
les problèmes de l'immigration étaient
notamment au centre de la réunion
aujourd'hui à paris de deux grandes
formations politiques françaises rpr et
parti socialiste agitée également les
deux formations par des dissensions
internes au parti socialiste en premier
lieu en pleine préparation de son
congrès le premier ministre michel
rocard est venu demander aux militants
et aux responsables du ps de
s'intéresser en priorité aux grands
problèmes qui agitent notre société et
le monde
il n'est pas sûr qu'il était vraiment
écouté rachid arhab frédéric basket
chassez le naturel il revient au galop
pour une fois le ps semblait avoir
oublié ses divergences internes pour
parler un peu de ce qui se passe à l'est
et à malte par exemple mais rien n'y a
fait
la lutte va du j'ose pas a rapidement
repris le dessus et éclipsé le tête à
tête gorbatchev bush
et pourtant ce matin michel rocard et
pierre mauroy avait tous deux lancé un
appel à l'unité des socialistes face aux
problèmes de la france et du monde
le premier ministre avait même été assez
ferme devant ses camarades nous ne
pourrons pas continuer longtemps ainsi
affirmé michel rocard autrement dit ces
sont les querelles de personnes sous
peine d'échec grave
ce soir certains responsables vont
jusqu'à parler de risque de
fractionnement du parti socialiste
visiblement la crise couve éclatera tél
ça n'est pas sûr au rpr le président du
mouvement jacques chirac son nez pris
cet après midi à monsieur mitterrand qui
l'accusent de réactiver régulièrement le
front national en jouant avec le feu sur
les problèmes de l'immigration mais au
rpr comme au ps les différences de
points de vue sur la création d'un parti
unique de l'opposition
voulue par les rénovateurs contre l'avis
des responsables actuels à plus retenu
l'attention que ce grand problème de
société
olivier lerner clément se gueule
compagnon je vous ai compris en écoutant
avec plus ou moins d'attention les huit
contributions développer à la tribune
par les rénovateurs les conservateurs et
ceux qui ne représentent qu'eux mêmes
jacques chirac à noter les bons et les
moins bons compagnons
alain carignon et philippe seguin ce
matin ont choisi le pistonné a un coût
pour se distingue pour certains d'entre
nous rien ou presque n'a changé sinon la
vitalité la cohésion de notre mouvement
pour d'autres dont je suis tout a changé
sauf la capacité d'initiatives et de
propositions de notre mouvement
jacques chirac applaudi mais alain juppé
reste de marbre
le courant rénovateur passe plutôt bien
dans cette salle qui découvre sa propre
diversité de pensée et les chefs tant
qu'ils sont chefs ont toujours raison
exemple l'union de l'opposition vécu
dans un parti unique
les rénovateurs sont pour jacques chirac
narines compte mais yann je ne peux pas
m'empêcher d'imaginer chaque fois que
j'entends ici ou là les uns ou les
autres
proposer des solutions miracles ils le
font avec des zones arrière-pensée tels
que le résultat est plutôt de la rendre
plus difficile que de la facilité en
fait il s'agissait d'une simple mise en
jambes
toute la question est de savoir
maintenant si la synthèse se fera non en
février prochain lors des assises
nationales du rpr entre rénovateurs et
conservateur jacques chirac n'a pas pu
ou n'a pas voulu trancher
au risque de décevoir et les uns et les
autres et maintenant l'actualité trente
années après dans la nuit du 2 décembre
1959 le barrage de malpasset construit
au dessus de fréjus dans le var cédait
subitement sous la pression des eaux
gonflées par trois journées de pluie
ininterrompue
ce fut sans doute la plus grande
catastrophe de l'après-guerre en france
423 morts et aujourd'hui personne parmi
les rescapés n'a encore vraiment oublié
reportage de dominique verdeilhan et
bernard ap ce soir-là à fréjus on
regardait achille zavatta dans la piste
aux étoiles
soudain la lumière s'est éteinte un
grondement a retenti dans la nuit une
eau boueuse s'est très vite engloutis
dans les habitations de la vallée du
reyran à 21h13 le barrage de malpasset
venait de se briser comme une vitre
libérant 50 millions de mètres cubes
d'eau trente ans après un panneau de
signalisation brisé des blocs de béton
éparpillés sur six kilomètres dans la
vallée témoin silencieux de cette
catastrophe
le barrage lui est resté tel quel trente
ans après les rescapés se souviennent un
bruit énorme bloqué commencent à rentrer
peut-être 10 15 cm pinette et a pris la
porte s est abattue et la grosse vague
est rentré j'ai vidé l'armoire et j'ai
pris mes deux frères
j'ai mis dedans la place dans la tête
d'une enfant les cris des gens toute la
nuit
bon ça c'est très dur oublier ensuite
les cadavres comme on sort puisque dans
le jardin de la villa nous étions en
retrait quand même 7
la vague meurtrière amis vingt-et-une
minutes pour aller du barrage au bord de
mer distants de 12 kilomètres
neuf cent soixante et une maisons ont
été détruites les arènes de fréjus ont
été le seul édifice à résister michel
allemand était ce soir-là au cinéma
saint raphaël
ses parents et sa soeur ont été eux
emportés par les eaux j'étais à une
station service une seule station
essence bp qui était qui se situe ici il
n'est plus rien rester
même plus les cuves un mois fut
nécessaire pour dresser un bilan huit
pour conclure qu'aucune faute n'avait
été commise et plusieurs années pour que
fréjus renaisse
c'est à partir de malpassé que prévu ça
commencé à grandir
on a connu le nom de fréjus et les
jambes sont venus s'y installer depuis
cette époque la plupart des rescapés
sont restés dans la région comme pour se
souvenir des 423 victimes de malpasset
toute cette semaine en france ça a été
consacrée à une campagne d'information
sur le sida nous y avons participé et
nous terminons ce soit avec le
douloureux problème de ceux qui ont été
contaminées par transfusion car ils sont
hémophiles on en compte à ce jour 1200
en france
témoignage d'un enfant et de sa famille
ce garçon est aujourd'hui séropositives
ce qui signifie que la maladie ne s'est
pas encore déclarée chez lui mais qu'il
est déjà contaminé ce soir ce garçon
geoffrey son père et sa mère ont décidé
donc de parler car ils en ont assez de
garder le silence ils veulent montrer
que malgré tout est bien ils vivent
comme une famille normale ils ont eu ce
courage car on le sait le problème
majeur des victimes de ce terrible mal
c'est la peur non seulement de mourir
bien évidemment mais aussi d'être rejeté
par les autres
reportage de jean daniel flaysakier et
françois granier geoffrey est ce que tu
sais je m'appelle tour d'italie que tu
es comment séropositifs ça veut dire
quoi si oui j'y vis dc comics
est-ce que les gens qui quittent
entourent savent que tu que tu est
porteur du virus
georges à midi et quand ils vont le
savoir
après après ce soir tu leur diras quoi
je suis mal je reviens je suis pas
malade
et tu crois qu'il n'a certains qui vont
compléter copains après ce soir tu crois
qu'ils ont tous restés comice est
tellement ils ont bien raison d'ailleurs
les copains de geoffrey de ne pas
changer leur attitude ils ne courent en
effet pas le moindre risque
preuve en est aucun des membres de la
famille de geoffrey nés séropositifs
aucun et pourtant dans cette maison on
ne prend aucune précaution particulière
dans la vie de tous les jours
arthur si nous la sympathique la scène
ils savent très bien il n'y a pas de
problème cc ça nous pose pour aucun des
niveaux de jeu la maison j'ai la maladie
jour une femme en cas de problème
les problèmes ils sont autres et surtout
sociaux et financiers
geoffrey fessée prise de sang dans
l'hôpital près de chez lui certes mais
il est suivi à paris une fois par mois à
500 km de la maison
et comme ils travaillent bien à l'école
sa maman ne veux pas qu'ils ratent la
classe alors il faut faire l'aller
retour dans la journée en avion le
mercredi cela coûte cher quand les deux
parents sont au chômage et que la
sécurité sociale ne rembourse que le
train et quand elles remboursent mal
aussi certains autres aux examens on
jongle un peu pour les voyages au on
déclare des voyages en voiture et on
veut en aviron bayonnais différence pour
les examens hors nomenclature jusqu'à
maintenant j'ai payé maintenant je
payerai plus j'ai dit j'ai décidé que
c'était terminé
donc je vais envoyer ses factures amis
cyclos des vins je pense qu'il ya un
moment où il faut prendre ses
responsabilités prendre ses
responsabilités c'est ce qu'a fait la
famille dubois en acceptant de parler
tous savent que demain sera très dur et
certainement pas plus dur que le silence
dans lequel ils sont mûrs et depuis cinq
ans et qui devenait aujourd'hui un peu
naïve
que les gens comprennent tout de suite
le message qu'on a voulu faire passer on
a pris des risques il fonctionne très
bien j'ai un coup de poker voilà on sait
qu' il y aura des réactions négatives
mais j'ai confiance en l'avenir human je
crois qu en informant c'est justement
pour ça que nous nous faisons cette
fascination
c'est justement pour informer les gens
que un séropositif peut vivre
normalement
si ces gens sont rejetés ils n'ont pas
envie de vivre il est uni de combattre
donc il faudrait que son message passe
aussi de ce côté là tu crois que quand
tu seras grand construire us otan sera
débarrassé ici qu'est ce t'en penses toi
qu'est ce que tu me dis qu'ils sont
punis tu crois que c'est possible et
ceux qui font de la recherche aux
juristes a envie de leur dire qu'ils se
dépêchent un peu la rédaction d'antenne
2 vous propose maintenant ce soir donc
et demain dans notre édition de 20
heures deux pages spéciales composées de
reportages réalisés en arménie à la
veille de la date anniversaire du
tremblement de terre qui a ravagé le
pays le 7 décembre dernier le bilan je
vous le rappelle 25000 pays
officiellement deux ou trois fois plus
selon des sources officieuses quoi qu'il
en soit un an après voici le constat
d'abord en premier lieu dans la plus
grande ville d'arménie touchée par le
séisme
lénine à cannes trois cent mille
habitants reporter thierry calmette
dominique mère
lénine à cannes la semaine dernière
place lénine l'horloge officielle de
moscou une heure de plus locale toujours
bloqué à la minute de la première
secousse 6,9 sur l'échelle de richter
les bâtiments d'état les plus anciens
supporters mieux le choc
pour le reste la ville détruite à 75%
trois cent mille habitants doumic
maisonnette un euphémisme nous dirions
barak bidonvilles il habite dedans ok
dollar immeubles détruits en ce début
d'hiver les plus réalistes tente
d'aveuglés les courants d'air en
construisant en dur et puis désespérés
ne lutte plus comme lily et ram 10 ans
avenue les lignes gradient son mari
devenu fou qu'il conduisait un autobus
au moment du séisme
le benjamin écrasé dans les ruines de
leur appartement sans eau l'électricité
un branchement de fortune marche deux ou
trois heures par jour et pas tous les
jours sans fenêtre le papier peint imite
la brique madame et radiant est au bout
du rouleau salaire moyen en arménie 120
roubles soit des touches que 75 au
rouble par mois c'est très difficile de
vivre avec ça dans les magasins d'état
les produits coûtent trop cher quand
rihanna mais souvent dans les magazines
là il n'y a rien qu'est ce qui vous
manque le plus aujourd'hui
le plus urgent ce qui me manque le plus
ce sont les vêtements et puis aussi la
nature
je n'ai pas de ce bon pour faire la
lessive
même pas pour me laver et nous
construirons un email dans dix quinze
ans peut-être
je ne sais pas d'inspecteurs est
d'inciter les messieurs chez coop
non ce n'est pas un cas isolé même les
riches lost à la même enseigne dans l'ex
russe et viennent de l'autre côté de la
ville rafik négociant 500 roubles par
mois
membre du pc conducteurs de locomotive
n'en peut plus toutes ces familles
habitent une douche alors osé imaginer
les fêtes de fin d'année pour les
enfants une provocation
les fêtes de fin d'année ça n'existe
plus dans notre situation on ne peut
même pas fêter quoi que ce soit tout ça
ça s'est arrêté il ya un an et l'école
pour les enfants une bicoque qui ne
ressemble pas à une école pas de
chauffage pas d'électricité
rien alors ils n'y vont plus nous vivons
comme des chiens il faut faire quelque
chose pour eux pas pour nous pour eux
pour que puissent vivre décemment
le gouvernement a promis la
reconstruction pour dans deux ans ils
ont dû oublier 1 0
les gens de lénine à cannes la fin
novembre en arménie s'appelle l'automne
d'auray une sorte d'été indien
mais depuis un an c'est l'hiver tous les
jours et pour longtemps
après lénine à cannes direction spitak
une cité de moindre importance qui se
trouvait pour son malheur située sur
l'épicentre même du tremblement de terre
et si une grande ville comme lénine à
cannes bénéficient guère on l'a vue
d'une reconstruction accélérée que dire
de ces régions rurales qui commence à
affronter les rigueurs de l'hiver
reporter et me roesch franck brisset
elle a 70 ans son mari 80 inlassablement
il retourne sur les ruines de leurs
maisons
histoire durable
mon dieu pourquoi tu fais cela cesse
comme toujours le vieil homme
un an après la maison il habitait depuis
qu'ils avaient fui les horreurs du
génocide de 1915
cette fois encore ils ont eu la vie
sauve mais 6 de leurs proches sont morts
sous les pierres du 7 décembre
depuis six mois ils ont trouvé refuge
dans une baraque mises à leur
disposition ils ont de quoi manger de
quoi se chauffer mais plus lent vie de
vivre comme si leur existence s'était
brutalement arrêté l'année dernière
l'avenir pour nous c'est de mourir
partir pour ne plus voir de tels
malheurs voilà ce que je souhaite
ce que j'attends jour et nuit et que nos
jeunes ne connaissent jamais pareille
blessure dans ces villages de montagne
autour de spitak l'hiver s'installe
bientôt il fera jusqu'à -30 degrés les
dégâts ont été énormes puisque nous
sommes exactement sur l'épicentre du
séisme
mais pas question de partir même s'il
faut se contenter d'un préfabriqué
bricoler
ici ou là des programmes de construction
sont en cours mais rien ne sera prêt
avant plusieurs semaines
sans doute plusieurs mois pas
d'électricité aujourd'hui dans la cabane
de greta une panne chroniques et les
bougies sont difficiles à trouver
dix-sept personnes s'entassent ici deux
familles qui se sont regroupés depuis le
séisme dans la catastrophe greta a perdu
un pied et donc son emploi au kolkhoze
avec sa maigre pension elle se croit
désormais considérée comme une marginale
improductif ils ont promis de fournir le
nécessaire en priorité à ceux qui ont eu
des victimes et aux invalides
ils ont promis qu'il ordonnerait des
abris mais c'est faux ils vont les
données les abris à qui ils veulent et
d'abord à ceux qui travaillent
moi je sert plus à rien à se requinquer
tamara 27 ans déjà dix mois sous cette
basse le temps impossible à chauffer son
mari blessé à la tête est incapable de
retravailler et il ne fait plus rien non
plus à la maison le petit dernier a tout
juste huit jours grâce à lui la famille
a touché à l'abri en dur mais pas le
lait dont le bébé a besoin c'est dur
c'est très dur bien sûr beaucoup plus
que pour les autres mais comment faire
après tant de morts je suis tellement
heureuse de cette naissance tant de mort
la mère de tamar elle semble ne jamais
devoir s'en remettre
elle a vieilli tout d'un coup et pas un
jour ne passe sans qu'elle aille se
recueillir sur la tombe de sa petite
fille
certains ont presque tout sacrifier pour
offrir à leurs morts ces stèles au
caractère si particulier
trop brusquement elle se sont ajoutés
par dizaines de milliers dans les
cimetières arménien
et dans son malheur l'arménie n'a pas
seulement à affronter les suites de
cette terrible catastrophe naturelle
elle se double du problème de ses
relations avec la république frontalière
musulmane d'azerbaïjan là le conflit
dure et rien ne s'arrange bien au
contraire
moscou ayant décidé que la région du
karabagh à majorité arménienne incluse
dans le territoire de la république
d'azerbaïdjan le resterai ce que les
arméniens n'accepte pas alors non
seulement les azéri font le blocus des
matériaux et des matières premières
nécessaires à la reconstruction devils
arménienne détruites par le tremblement
de terre mais cela se double donc
aujourd'hui à la frontière entre les
deux pays d'un véritable état de guerre
mal contrôlée par l'armée rouge
officiellement pourtant envoyé là bas
pour faire tampon entre les deux
populations reporter tir icade m
dominique merlet poste frontière de
terre côté arménien l'armée soviétique
veille mais ne bouge pas
de l'autre côté l'azerbaïdjan les azéri
les turcs pour les arméniens agressé
presque tous les jours alors on assiste
à une scène surprenante le chef de la
police de goris discutant tranquillement
avec un berger arménien à harnes
c'était vendredi dernier en urss
magique pourquoi vous ne le dites pas
gorbatchev ne nous laisse que le couteau
pour qu'on puisse se trancher la gorge
je n'ai pas peur de le dire il nous est
gorge mon mari hébergés dans la montagne
et hier ils ont enlevé deux bergers dans
les villages frontaliers l'exaspération
gagne les azéri assiègent les isoler et
multiplie les razzias la veille de notre
arrivée deux bergers enlevés ainsi que
leurs troupeaux marc au vif nous ne
savons pas le frère d'une des victimes
raconte
mais at-il assisté à la scène non il n'y
a pas de témoin mais nous avons suivi
les traces et c'est sûr que les bergers
les moutons ont été enlevés c'était qui
d'héberger comme vous ou des groupes
armés non non ce ne sont pas des bergers
ce sont des groupes armés qui agit sous
le nom de front populaire azéri les
villes s de cornies d'or nasa revivre
sous leur garde et azéri d'en face qui
ne se gênent plus pour repérer des coups
de main en territoire arménien sur la
frontière les soldats soviétiques venue
de moldavie servent de tampons mais
laisse faire les uns et les autres
génies ce jour nous sommes dans une
position difficile vraiment très
difficile à cause des deux peuples mais
nous devons défendre les intérêts des
uns et des jours jours
quelle que soit leur nationalité c'est
notre service notre mission mais si l'on
vous tirent dessus vous avez le droit de
riposter
nous pouvons pour y poster si on nous
tire dessus
si la vie de quelqu'un est en danger on
nous a montré des traces de tracteurs
incendiés on nous a raconté des
histoires terribles le 11 octobre
dernier rang arakelian s'est fait
mitrailler sur la route de goris alarmes
automatiques précise-t-il
et il insiste pour nous montrer ses
cicatrices il aurait reconnu ses
agresseurs vêtus de noirs venus du
village d'en face il était 5 heures de
l'après midi
quand j'ai vu qu'il tirait sur la
voiture devant nous j'ai arrêté la
camionnette je suis descendu et c'est à
ce moment là en me retournant j'ai pris
une balle dans l'épaule et j'ai crié ce
sont des turcs ce sont des turcs
une commission denquête venus de moscou
étudie les projectiles et les impacts
sur la camionnette
impossible de les filmer pour les berges
des arméniens cette situation de
guérilla avec l'azerbaïdjan ne leur
laisse plus le choix qu'entre la
houlette et le fusil et déjà se forment
des bandes armées
la montée du nationalisme en arménie un
autre reportage que vous pourrez suivre
ce soir dans notre dernière édition et
puis demain soir donc à 20h20 environ
une autre page spéciale
à retenir encore dans l'actualité de ce
samedi activités sportives les deux
demi-finales du tournoi des maîtres à
new york vous pourrez les suivre ces
deux rencontres de tennis ce soir sur
antenne 2 becker mcenroe d'un côté et
puis de l'autre côté et devers contre
l'inde
et puis dans un tout autre genre de
sport voici les résultats du championnat
d'orthographe qui se disputaient cette
après midi sur notre chaîne sous la
direction de bernard pivot
nous sommes quelques-uns des résultats
ça fait toujours plaisir catégorie
junior c'est monsieur raphaël une riche
19 ans ya gagné une faute ennemis
catégorie senior amateur
laurent mort et bailly de rennes une
faute et puis bien zéro faute dans la
catégorie des professionnels
jacques fils est de strasbourg zéro
faute et là sur ma feuille en a marqué
zéro faute avec un bien il y avait un
tir c'est aussi cet après midi qui se
courait voici les résultats qui
s'inscrivent sur votre écran vous gagnez
un petit peu plus de 4500 francs 4580
exactement si vous à jouer le 4e set le
11 et pour le quarté + cv ajouté le 5
ça vous donne un résultat aux alentours
des dix sept mille francs voilà ce
journal déterminer tout de suite après
lé prévisions météo avec josé blanc
lapierre et son sans-faute habituel sans
faute également pour philippe gassot
tout à l'heure et qui vous présentera
les toutes dernières informations du
jour je vous souhaite une excellente
soirée sur notre chaîne bien entendu et
je vous donne rendez-vous à demain 13
heures précises
bonsoir